a different unique villain we knew this
film be coming off Thanos be coming off
kill monger how do we find a villain
that is very different very unique and
when people see the movie I think
they'll see that we found it in ghosts
like that is that is what we want from
jonah anthony russo anna anna bohn and
ryan fleck are not with us tonight
because they're on location in the last
couple weeks of Captain Marvel and James
Gunn who's who's working on guardians
three right now we want all of those
unique voices Ryan Coogler who might be
around here somewhere
that's how it works is finding these
filmmakers great visions who can elevate
sort of the fun ideas and some of the
stories that we have hey everybody it's
Charlie we got a whole bunch of Avengers
phase 4 stuff to talk about like you saw
Kevin Feige doing a bunch of press for
ampion and the wasp naturally
everybody's using it as an opportunity
to try and get information about what's
happening after Avengers 4 so he did
give us a pretty good timeline on when
they're thinking about developing
certain big properties because people
have been talking about Thunderbolts
Young Avengers even powerpack a force
including Eternals which is actually up
a little bit sooner than you would
expect so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so starting with the big
stuff first Young Avengers like the
newest thing on the list of phase four
movies that we've heard about like Black
Widow and Eternals he said right now in
the movies that we're getting in the
next couple of years they're planting
the seeds for Young Avengers
particularly characters like Cassie Lang
who becomes stature in the comic so read
his quote here he says we've always been
big fans of powerpack and figuring that
out so where and when will we see the
evolution of that I don't know and
certainly taking our cue from the comics
as we always do that's why we wanted
Cassie a very young Cassie in this movie
to be inspired by her father just
planting seeds so part of the idea that
you've seen from the ant-man the wasp
trailers is the Cassie Lang little tiny
Cassie Lang says I wish I could be a
hero like you dad but she's a little
girl so of course she's not going to be
a superhero for a long time
but you all remembered that we got a
casting notice for what seems like an
older version of Cassie Lang because
there's supposed to be some minimal time
jump between Avengers 3 in the beginning
of Avengers 4 so when he says they're
planting seeds for things like powerpack
and Young Avengers that's what he's
talking about showing you a vision of
something before they sort of fixed the
universe in the timeline resets to what
it should have been before Avengers
infinity war then several years down the
road once we get through another
Avengers cycle or two we incorporate the
x-men characters they have enough really
young characters to actually do a young
Avengers movie so there are a couple
properties that you could do alongside
traditional Avengers films so like you
have main Avengers films like infinity
war Avengers for young avengers
powerpack Avengers Academy would be
considered something a little bit
different from that
like if you had old man Tony Stark come
back for a young Avengers film so that
they could do like a Breakfast Club
situation
well they battle Kang the Conqueror
through time and space you could do that
in a smaller way from what you would
consider a traditional Avengers film
like a big 200 million dollar film you
would have to spend that much money on
it but right now the only characters
that they've teased that would be a part
of that young Avengers team I wouldn't
think spider-man because by the time we
get to that like say we get through to
more Avengers rounds by the time we get
to Avengers 6 which will probably
definitely see some x-men take part in
Tom Holland in real life will be the
same age as Chris Hemsworth was during
the first Avengers film
no hard feelings Point Break you've got
a mean swing kid
revenger
[Music]
so think about how old Thor looks in the
first Avengers film like he's a pretty
well-developed character by the time we
got to that Tom Holland will be a pretty
old version of spider-man so for all of
these that wanted an older more mature
hardcore version of spider-man in the
MCU Tom Holland is slowly aging into
that and based on the way that they're
going with the spider-man films we'll
get through that third spider-man film
where he graduates from high school
before we get to any kind of young
Avengers film or anything like that and
if he was dubbed an Avenger during
infinity war so I think regardless of
his current biological age you could
consider him in a list Avenger not just
because he's a super popular comic book
character but just remember there's a
lot of stuff that has to happen before
they can do a young Avengers film you
have to introduce those other characters
like Miss Marvel Kamala Khan would be
another good example of a candidate for
a movie like that
just a much much younger version of what
you would consider a traditional
Avengers level character so I haven't
talked too much about powerpack because
that's sort of an oddball property if
they do Fantastic Four and they work
their way up to Franklin and valaria
Richards don't know if they would ever
do those characters but if they want to
do that their children would also be
good candidates for a Young Avengers
power-packed film but the problem with
characters like Franklin Richards is
he's almost 200 P for a film like that
like Thor and Captain Marvel are two of
the most powerful non celestial beings
in the MCU right now Franklin Richards
is almost more powerful than that so be
kind of weird to have to balance his
character with the other Young Avengers
characters without detuning his powers
or making them more powerful but they've
also talked about a Thunderbolts movie
the actress that plays ghost Hannah John
came in said that she totally wants to
come back for a Thunderbolts film they
still have Baron Zemo they have Frank
Rizzo's crossbones they have plenty of
mid-level to a-list villains that they
could put in a Thunderbolts movie like
Michael Keaton's vulture character would
be a good Thunderbolts character but you
have to remember that a lot of
spider-man characters and a lot of x-men
characters will be entering the universe
shortly so the list just gets deeper and
deeper and deeper the more awesome
villains they have that aren't dead at
the end of some of these movies the more
people you could put in a Thunderbolts
team-up but I'm kind of hoping we see a
Norman Osborn or like a really big
a-list
villain that they could have to lead
that team Norman Osborn is just a
character that they've used so much in
the spider-man films before we got to
Tom on that I think that they're
chilling on him a little bit before they
reintroduce him but a lot of these plans
the Kevin Feige has been talking about
are just in service of the very very
different-looking Marvel Cinematic
Universe that he's been teasing so
eternals is sort of like a whole
separate thing because that's actually
more real than this young Avengers movie
that he's talking about like young
Avengers is just an idea that he has
right now eternals is something that
they're moving forward on full steam
ahead like there's a rumored Eternals
character that we're gonna see during
Avengers 4 right now the rumor is is
that it's Kronos if you're not a big
comic book reader that Stannis's
grandfather they are ancient so the way
he talks about the Eternals he actually
gave a quote so I'll read it in a second
talks about it like they're planning on
doing the film set in the past here's
his quote here he says the Eternals you
know it's kind of an ancient aliens kind
of sci-fi trope that we think would be
fun to explore someday so that's the
idea that ancient aliens were
responsible for the evolution of the
human race so Ethan goes on to say one
of the cool things about that property
in what Jack Kirby did with it and
what's been done with it in recent years
is that they've been around for a long
time talking about the Eternals
characters you know there's this notion
of all these myths and legends that we
know from ancient times that were
inspired by the Eternals characters so
think about the ideas of them
introducing really powerful myths into
the history of the earth then showing
you those characters set during the far
past but because the MCU changes a lot
of things about comic book characters
like ego the Living Planet was changed
dramatically from his comic book self
just expect whatever they do with that
character to be a little bit different
but just let me know in the comments
they do a young Avengers film and say
like four or five years who do you want
them to include in that assuming that
they introduce a bunch more characters
to put in that within the next couple of
films what'll happen next is is I'll
post my non-spoilery ant-man and the
wasp review that should be up Wednesday
morning while you wait for that click
here for more new Avengers 4 and click
here for more cool infinity war behind
the scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]